[Music]
this is a story about a man who spoke to
demons a man who went by many names in
his life
the beast brother perp duro or angk fin
he was an occultist a student of the
dark arts and supernatural phenomena
founder of the religion thelma and a
publisher of books on magic and the
paranormal his followers regarded him as
a visionary and a champion of free
expression in a close-minded society his
enemies branded him as insane and
capable of great cruelty to those around
him the devil incarnate or a troubled
visionary that was simply misunderstood
it's all a matter of perspective
this is the story of aleister crowley
[Music]
aleister crowley was born on the 12th of
october 1875 in the sleepy english town
of leominton spa his father edward
crowley was a preacher and belonged to a
fringe christian sect known as the
plymouth brethren they took a radical
fundamentalist view to the bible meaning
that whatever was written down was meant
to be taken literally at its worst this
included the subjugation of women and
the persecution of homosexuals his
preaching career was cut short however
when in 1886 he died of tongue cancer
from a young age alistair was sent to a
number of boarding schools he was a
strange boy preferring his own company
instead of playing with other children
as a result he was often subject to
bullying sometimes by his teachers
this troubled child grew into a troubled
teenager he began to question his strict
christian upbringing and enjoyed
pointing out inconsistencies in the
bible at the same time he was often
caught smoking drinking and even
visiting prostitutes horrified his
mother would nickname him the beast
which is a monster from the book of
revelation a nickname that crowley would
soon delight in
in 1895 at the age of 19 alistair
enrolled at the university of cambridge
to study english literature he developed
a love for chess and romantic poetry
reading the works of lord byron edward
john trolloni and percy shelley it was
during this time when alastair developed
an unexplainable attraction to a fellow
student herbert charles pollock the
feeling was mutual and the two entered a
brief and passionate relationship
their commitment to one another was soon
to end for alistar developed a deeper
love the occult
spending days at a time in old dusty
libraries alastair discovered books of a
more mystical nature it had started
innocently with religious texts from
around the world but he soon delved into
darker material works like the lesser
key of solomon a 16th century grimoire
of spells rituals and evil spirits his
morbid curiosity with magic and the dark
arts evolved into an obsession and he
soon decided to devote his life to
occultism
having left cambridge failing to finish
his degree alistar was able to live off
the money that he'd inherited from his
father from a young age alistair was
extraordinarily wealthy this allowed him
to travel around the world and pursue
his expensive hobbies chief among which
was mountain climbing something he
gained recognition for among
mountaineering circles but crowley was
keen to progress his occult education in
november 1898 he was introduced to the
hermetic order of the golden dawn the
group believed to possess ancient
knowledge they studied esoteric
teachings medieval jewish kabbalah and
performed magical ceremonies which
included ritualistic drug taking members
of this group included arthur conan
doyle the author of sherlock holmes
adopting the name brother perduro
alastair impressed all those around him
displaying an extensive knowledge of
occult literature as a result he quickly
rose through the ranks but his roguish
lifestyle of excessive drug taking and
bisexuality made him a controversial
figure and led to a number of feuds with
fellow initiates those around him spoke
of his quote unappeasable desire to
control people and that he also had
quote a tendency to quarrel savagely
with anyone who disagreed with him many
fellow members refused him from
ascending further ranks a schism soon
developed within the order which led to
alastair leaving shortly after
with the order and its rigid hierarchy
crowley retreated to travelling with the
funds his father had left him he
journeyed to japan china sri lanka and
india he continued to climb and even
joined an early expedition to climb the
second highest peak on earth k2 during
his travels he was introduced to eastern
philosophy he studied the teachings of
taoism and buddhism as well as
practicing yoga he decided to include
various hard drugs into his curriculum
like hashish opium and certain
hallucinogenic substances in 1902 at the
age of 29 alistair found himself in
paris there he met a woman named rose
edith kelly who was also interested in
the occult although she was initially
betrothed to someone else the two had an
affair and swiftly got married for their
honeymoon they decided to go to egypt as
with all things alistar did this trip
would prove to be far from normal in
usual crowley fashion he set up a shrine
in their hotel suite and began
recounting spells and incantations
invoking the various egyptian gods what
happened next is crowley's later
recollection
the story goes that his wife rose
suddenly fell faint and became
unresponsive all she could murmur with
the words they are waiting for you
they as it turned out was the god horus
as if led by a spirit his wife took him
to a nearby museum all the way to
estelle dating to the reign of pharaoh
hap chipset looking down at the exhibit
number it read 666 the number of the
beast
suddenly a voice from the depth of
alistar's mind called out it called
itself iwas and it claimed to be an
angel it told alastair to write down all
that it said into a book for the next
three days iowa's dictated its words to
alastair who dutifully wrote them all
down what he was left with was a small
tome entitled the book of the law
opening the first pages the book was
replete with spells as well as
discourses and philosophy a key teaching
of this book was that humanity would
soon enter a new age the aeon of horus
in this time mankind will overthrow
christianity and finally take control of
their own destiny to achieve this goal
there was but one simple commandment
quote do what thou wilt every man and
woman is a star the word of sin is
restriction
in other words whatever you feel like
doing go and do it regardless of popular
opinion or conventional morality
believing himself to be a reincarnation
of an egyptian prophet and
kosu crowley returned to london and
founded a new religion he called it
thalamer a greek word meaning desire it
was based on the teachings found in the
book of the law and promoted a life of
hedonism and radical free will it was a
fusion of a number of religious
traditions mixing elements of western
occultism jewish kabbalah theravada
buddhism and yoga to accompany spiritual
practice crowley advocated the heavy use
of psychedelics in 1907 he founded his
own secret order the a a believed to
stand for argentium astrum the latin for
silver star owing to crowley's notoriety
in occult circles the aaa quickly grew
in number soon he released a periodical
for its members the equinox during this
time it was rumored that iwas had
contacted him again and instructed him
to write more holy books things were
going well for aleister and his nascent
movement but nothing good lasts forever
now a leader of his own religion with a
philosophy to justify his own behavior
crowley enjoyed a lavish lifestyle he
continued to travel take increasingly
heavier drugs and have affairs with both
women and men at the same time his
marriage to rose began to break down
despite his own scandalous lifestyle he
became frustrated that his wife had
developed alcoholism in 1909 he divorced
her on the grounds of adultery after
their marriage fell apart rose's
addiction worsened and she was admitted
into an institution in 1911. eventually
all the travelling drug taking and
libertinism had caught up with crowley
the inheritance left by his father had
now dried up what's more his addiction
to drugs had severely worsened to treat
his asthma his doctor prescribed him
heroin to which he soon developed a
crippling dependency during the outbreak
of world war one he was living in new
york gaining a small income through
writing short stories and articles he
even had a brief stint working as a
double agent for british intelligence
after the war his attempts at spreading
thelma in the united states were largely
unsuccessful and it soon came time for
alastair to leave in 1920 crowley rented
a small house in sicily bringing some of
his most dedicated followers with him
there they set up the abbey of thelma
and soon began to accept fresh disciples
in the hopes of advancing the eon of
horus the abbey of thelama was designed
to be a utopia free from all the
restrictions that plagued modern life
aside from a few rituals to the sun god
ra and a weakly gnostic mass most of the
members were left to pursue their own
interests crowley took a number of
lovers and ran the commune as its de
facto leader with the
responsibility-free lifestyle advocated
by thelma the abbey quickly became
dilapidated it was full of litter and
human waste and stray dogs would often
roam the building in these unsanitary
conditions one of the acolytes died of
mysterious causes newspapers got wind of
this and began to speculate that had
been a part of a blood ritual
not long after alastair gained infamy
and the myth of mr crowley emerged
british periodical john bull described
him as quote the wickedest man in the
world others accused him of worshipping
satan some believed that he actually was
satan the abbey of thalamer gradually
fell apart and all the members
eventually left the commune the
abandoned building remains there today
although it's now vandalized and
overgrown for modern practitioners of
thalamer it remains a site of pilgrimage
a memory of something that could have
been
disgraced and destitute crowley returned
to england and retired from public life
in 1929 he soon been married to a woman
named maria teresa sanchez although he
continued to have the occasional affair
every now and then he spent the
remainder of his days in the seaside
town of hastings there he wrote a few
more books and offered students tuition
for his magic his final publication was
the book of thoth a tarot deck that
remains popular today in 1947 alastair
crowley developed chronic bronchitis and
died peacefully in his sleep at the age
of 72.
there's much that can be said about the
life of aleister crowley but perhaps a
1915 vanity fair article put it best
quote a legend has been built around his
name he is a myth no other man has so
many strange tales told about him
crowley himself once wrote that quote 1
000 years from now the world will be
sitting in the sunset of crolianity
we've yet to see this outcome so you
have to wait until the year 29 47. his
legacy can be seen in strange and
surprising places perhaps his largest
influence has been in the revival of
pagan practices religions like wicca
have increased in numbers from the 20th
century well into the modern era many of
crowley's books and teachings have been
widely published and remain essential
reads for all those interested in magic
and the dark arts one of his strangest
legacies has been in the world of music
crowley has since become an icon of a
number of counter-cultural movements
especially in punk and rock and roll he
can be found here on the cover of the
beatles 1967 album sergeant pepper's
lonely hearts club band crowley's words
have made their way into the lyrics of
songs by david bowie aussie osborne and
iron maiden led zeppelin guitarist jimmy
page even bought crowley's scottish
manor bolskan lodge but soon left the
property after claiming that it was
haunted but for all his fame are we
guilty of glorifying the life of
alastair crowley by all accounts he was
not a likable man many biographers
recount his exceptional cruelty and
ability to alienate those close to him
his conversations with spirits and
demons could be a symptom of an
underlying mental health condition
exacerbated by his untreated addiction
to alcohol and drugs today we might
throw all kinds of medical diagnoses at
him sociopathy narcissistic personality
disorder disassociation and drug-induced
schizophrenia
genius insane visionary fraud free
thinker cult leader perhaps he's ordered
these things or none of them however you
choose to remember him alistair crowley
will be remembered nonetheless
hey thanks for watching this video i
really hope you enjoyed this one the
life aleister crowley is fascinating
i've added some further reading in the
description if you want to delve deeper
if you like this video and want to see
more why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye